now how could we I mean you know it
works with the formula how can we
actually show that this is true okay let
me try to illustrate it for you right so
you might have noticed this is not
exactly the same tip watching yesterday
it's off just by a little bit right so
let's try and draw this thing okay I
want to try and visually that's why I've
called this illustration I want to try
to visually demonstrate that this is
true okay so what I want to think of is
all of these as areas okay yeah okay
right thank you display this let's take
that one I want to draw that as a square
which is one by one in dimensions okay
so the square that represents my first
term okay now how would he draw the rest
of the terms I'm just going to imagine
that there's another squint view the
same dimensions okay if I wanted an area
of 1/2 how could I figure that out how
could I put that is right well I can
take this imaginary swear I could do it
right so this here this part right this
has an area one this triangle has their
own behalf okay all right now that the
next term which is a quarter so this is
left over imaginary triangle I can get a
quarter out by dividing in half again so
that one is yes great
now where do I get it hey I can't write
anywhere like I suppose this one is okay
okay the next one will be a sixteenth
even though I haven't written it
so these symmetric triangle is an eighth
so if I have it again this way this
right that's a sixteen okay do you need
more proof kappahd I need to go that's
going to be one on 32 you can see as n
approaches infinity I'm approaching
something what am i appreciated a
rectangle which is one unit by two units
Atlanta
okay so I mean that's not proof there is
actually a book it's called proof
without words you're gonna book it up it
has it's filled with stuff like this
just diagrams and there's no other
explanation attached to it they just
like you would okay right now those of
you who wiki yesterday has anyone come
up with an answer yet dividing the three
okay right so for those of you who were
yesterday I took um I took this series I
left off the one right so you can see
that if I left off the one the
difference if they I'm just looking at
this cut up square at the bottom okay
now the ratio here is a half we were
experimenting with what happens if the
ratio is minus 1/2 okay and you still
start at this point
okay now using this formula you can go
ahead and verify we found that the Sun
would be 1/3 okay we found that 1/2
minus 1/4 plus 1/8 minus of 16 and so on
was going to be equal to 1/3 and I said
can you draw this just like we have
drawn this okay
any takers I just gave you a few minutes
to try it out what why Louis because you
already knew all that stuff before
nevermind I'm gonna I'm gonna give it a
go cuz I'm running out of time okay now
here's the series okay just to make
things a little clearer I'm gonna write
a bit more of it okay I'm gonna keep
going
what's the next time on 64 that should
be enough now we're contending that is
equal to 1/3 okay now to try and make
this a little clearer right I think I
think that drugs are selfish than
negatives right if I would do with this
I'd have to have like you know areas and
all right so instead I'm going to try to
count for the negatives in a way which
doesn't have negatives in it will have a
square in a second but how am I going to
get rid of all these negatives well it
just sort of happens that every negative
here in every negative term the series
can you see is matched up to another
term which is positive but bigger you
see that for example 1/4 - quarter and a
half I can match them up together right
and this negative and this 1/2 together
they're gonna be a positive yes what are
they another minute okay in the same way
I'm gonna keep hearing up there's a
panicky on what do they give you equal
to a 16 that's what I meant to say all
right now what what make the next one be
okay now hold on a second okay okay you
follow me are you following that's right
I've got a new series this time the
first term is a quarter and the ratio is
also on top ok got this I can draw let's
have a go okay I'm going to go back to
my square because squares are easy to
divide up quarters okay so that's a very
good angle
oh okay yeah all right help me out here
now how I gonna draw quarters out of
this well I just put some imaginary
lines yeah okay so where's my first
quarter gonna make I can pick any of it
let's do the top left it's a big oh
there's a quarter okay now the next
thing I want to have it is a sixteenth
that's a quarter of a quarter right so
which way will I go well I could go
anywhere I think this is probably gonna
be the most awful place to do it
so again I'm going to divide it up and
there is so I should have done wise
those same directions that doesn't
there's a 16 where is one sixty-fourth
I'm gonna do it again
right
okay now can you see what's happening
you see what's happening what's going on
can you see the third you see the third
for every area that I have shaded I have
two that are exactly the same size which
I've not shaded that's 1/3 of this area
and this is 1/3 of this area and this is
what this area so if I do that as n
approaches infinity the whole thing
ought to be equal to 1/3 okay you can
even see it's sort of like I'm dividing
up into you know an equal sort of
section okay so it took me a little
while I'm staring and it - I did
actually try something with negatives in
but it's not getting to fusion so I
think I think this sort of makes sense
of it ok
now do you have any to do that not
really by just I just want to show you
that the numbers these numbers they
actually mean something it's not like
something you just spit out a formula
and who cares